Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start to shake.
I'm a cybernetic organism
episode is brought to you by Vimeo pro,
which is the ideal video hosting
platform for entrepreneurs, and in fact,
a bunch of my startups already use
Vimeo pro including wealth front,
who uses it to explain how
wealth front works task grab,
it uses it to tell the company story
and there are many other names you would
recognize among their customers, airbnb,
Etsy, et cetera. Why do they use it?
Well,
Vimeo pro provides enterprise level
video hosting for a fraction of the usual
cost. Features include gorgeous
high quality playback with no ads,
up to 20 gigabytes of
video storage every week.
Unlimited plays in views and a
fully customizable video player,
which can include your logo,
custom outro, et cetera.
You also get VIP support and you get
all of this for just one 99 per year.
That's $17 a month with no complicated
bandwidth calculations or hidden fees,
and you can try it risk free for 30 days.
So check it out.
vimeo.com forward slash business.
That's vim,
e o.com forward slash business and
use Promo Code Tim to get 25% off.
That's a special discount just
for you guys. So check it out.
vimeo.com forward slash
business Promo Code Tim.
Hello Ladies and germs. This
is Tim Ferriss, otherwise
known as Faye you tongue,
but I'm not going to
ask you to call me that.
And this is another episode of the
Tim Ferriss Show where my job is to
deconstruct world class
performers or teachers,
oftentimes both in many different areas
and that could range from chess to
sports to acting, to
government, to military.
And this time we have an incredible
meditative thinker and teacher,
uh, specifically in the Buddhist
tradition. So Tara Brock,
I have been looking forward to speaking
with Tara for many, many, many months.
Tara is a phd in clinical psychology and
one of the leading teachers of Buddhist
thinking and meditation
in the Western World.
She is the founder of the insight
meditation community in Washington DC.
And her lectures,
which are fantastic.
Our downloaded hundreds of
thousands of times every month.
I was first introduced to Tara's work
by another guest on this podcast,
Maria Popova, who's amazing. You
should listen to her episode as well.
Soon thereafter,
looked like the universe was conspiring.
A friend who's also a neuroscience PhD
recommended her book radical acceptance.
She claimed it was life changing and all
of my red flags went up and it ended up
exceeding all expectations. It really
had a profound impact on my life.
So it's my hope that this tactical
conversation offers you techniques for
addressing all sorts of issues ranging
from loneliness, anger, hatred,
the quote trance of unworthiness
and quote and much more, uh,
Tara has had a meaningful
impact on my life.
And of course I wish the same for you.
That's why I invited her
to pee on the podcast.
And for those of you who know my
fondness for stoic philosophy,
I think Tara's work and certain facets
of Buddhism in fact are a fantastic
complement to all of my talking
and reading about Seneca,
Marcus Aurelius and the other favorites.
So without further ado,
please enjoy a conversation that I really
enjoyed and a wide ranging romp across
all sorts of subjects and
topics with Tara Brock.
Tara,
welcome to the show.
I'm delighted to be with you,
Tim
and I am having a bit of Deja Vu all
over again is a one very wise man.
Once said, because I've heard so
many of your guided meditations,
it's surreal to be talking to you live.
I do. Do you get that a lot? Do you had,
do you have people come up to you and
have to do a double take with your voice
or people recognize you in restaurants
because they've heard your guided
meditations?
Yeah. That and they'll say, oh, you
look so much littler than I thought
and then I'll start speaking and they'll
go into a kind of hypnotic trance.
I've been introduced to you through many
different people and eventually almost
in the same way that meditation kind
of knocked on my door until I finally
answered.
Uh,
Maria Popova who runs a site called
brain pickings is just just one of my
favorite people and brought you
up on this podcast. In fact,
and then a number of my other friends,
a friend named Olivia who also brought
you up and it just got to the point where
specifically,
uh,
your guided meditations and radical
acceptance head been introduced into my,
my life or my slipstream my consciousness.
So many different ways.
I felt like perhaps it was time for me
to sit down and take a look at things at.
So first off,
I wanted to just thank you for the work
that you do because it's had a very
positive impact on my life and based
on the response of my audience on many
people who are likely listening to
this, this interview. So first off,
I just wanted to thank you for that.
Thank you. I appreciate hearing
it and it's very neutral,
but I won't go there right this moment,
but thank you for how much you're,
what you're doing ripples out.
Yeah.
It's just every everyday. Yeah.
Slogging along in my own way,
although if people could see it, sometimes
I think how the sausage is made. I,
uh, I, I not so much worry,
but part of the reason I,
I usually decline journalists want to
follow me around for three to five days.
I'm like,
you might be envisioning something
that is very different from my reality.
I think you see me like snowboarding
in the Alps and then taking, uh,
taking some type of zip line,
like into a bathtub where I'm reciting
poetry or whatever the image might be.
I have no idea what the images,
I'm like most of the time it
looks like I'm just sitting there,
I know can be awful ordinary
from the inside out.
Extraordinary pose.
So I was,
I was hoping we might
start, uh, where, uh, where,
where things began,
uh,
and to rewind the clock a little bit and
just give people a retrospective of how
you got to,
to the point where you're
teaching Buddhist meditation
and mindfulness and so on.
Um, and I have a little
bit of the background from
radical acceptance and having
read that, but for those people
who were unfamiliar with your work,
maybe you could give just a brief,
uh,
a brief overview of your background.
But I think that'd be a
helpful place to start. Right?
Sure. Well, if I go back, you
know, more to the teams, you know,
I was completely,
I remember when I first went to a class
on comparative religion and you know,
we've got a whole mess of them introduced.
And I decided that Buddhism was at the
very bottom of my list because it just
like, you know, why would
I want to give up desire?
I was a total heat and nest and I love
my desires, you know, whether it was,
you know, nature and athletics
or drugs or sex or parties,
you know, it's like, why give
up desire? And it wasn't,
it was about another five
years until I got it.
But that wasn't the message. It wasn't
give up desire. It was, you know, not be,
not have that desire to be a tyrant over
your life, you know, not be possessed.
But, so I, I was, uh, you know,
just a thrill seeking and also type A,
kind of a,
uh, teen, very hardworking
and hard playing.
And where was this?
I grew up in Montclair, New Jersey and a,
which we all called the hub
of the universe because it
seemed like the center of
everything.
And then I went into college thinking
I was going to be a lawyer and when I
graduated I moved right into an Ashram.
So something happened in there.
Nothing happened. I'm so curious.
I mean, what triggered that?
Was it a conversation, their
particular movie or book? I mean,
how did you go from preparing to
be a lawyer to going to an Ashram?
Well, I got, there are a
number of influence as part of,
it's the times, you know, I,
I went to college and it was,
um,
social activism and I was very antiwar,
very involved with left wing
politics and the kinds of,
the Combo of that with,
um,
psychedelics combined with,
uh, just the whole, you know,
coming to the east east,
coming to the west and introducing yoga.
I began to do yoga in my junior
or senior year in college.
And my reality shifted. Tim,
you know, it's like, um,
I was still, I had a, I've
always had an interest in, uh,
you know, learning and academics
to some degree, but I was like,
I was passionate about discovering,
you know,
what is the nature of the universe,
what is reality?
And I've always fascinated the psyche,
like how do these minds work?
So I knew that somehow I knew,
I just had kind of had to give
myself to that. So when I graduated,
um, I went to what's called
the summer solstice gathering.
It was a big yoga meditation gathering and
there was just this experience that,
um,
there was a mystery that
was so much bigger than the
world that I normally lived
in, that that was the
thing to commit myself to.
So I really literally went from college
right into an Ashram community and
Ashrams, uh, for those that are,
are listening, I don't know, it's a,
it's a spiritual community where
practice yoga and meditation,
we'd get up at three 30 in the morning
and start with a cold shower as the first
beginning of the day was just
getting into it, cold shower.
And then doing
a lot of very vigorous yoga and
chanting and meditation and you know,
after a few hours I identified
the day feeling, uh,
just absolutely ablaze with,
you know,
both energy and also very,
very peaceful and happy.
And then during the
day, because, you know,
I carried all my type a
stuff into Osram list,
I would either just, I
was kind of, Oh, you know,
we're a pretty driven Yogi player.
You've got it. It's amazing.
We all, we do that. We,
I've seen pretty much everyone I know
get into spiritual life or spiritual
practice,
but bring all their normal
egoic neurotic stuff into it.
So I did that and I, I remember,
I mean we all have different
ways of doing it. For me,
I had this idea that if I
worked really hard at it,
I could get enlightened and six or seven
years and I have no idea where I got
that number. That was my, you know, I just
kinda figured I really throw myself in.
And so I would sometimes go
to different teachers and say,
well, so what else can I do? Cause
you know, I was a pretty, you know,
I was going at it like as a group, we
would get up at three 30 in the morning,
but I'd often get up at two 30 so
I can get a little extra. And, and,
and I don't say this by the way, with
pride. I mean, I was, you know, I've,
I've learned since then, but, um, so
I'd asked this question, you know,
what else can I do?
And to a tee,
the response would be just
relax. And then I go, oh,
just relax. And that would become my
next, you know, practice. No, it's,
I'm going to do this now.
You're going to wake up 30
minutes earlier to relax.
Exactly. Right. Exactly right.
It's like race, race, race
to get there and wait. But,
you know. Anyway, so that was kind of, um,
those were my earliest
years in the Ashram.
I was pretty driven and trying really
hard to purify and become a better person.
And, um, you know,
I got drawn both because I intuited,
you know,
this,
this mystery and two did a kind of love
that really was possible to and have it
in an express and an
awareness that was very vast.
And I also was drawn because I wanted
to become a better person and I,
I spent a lot of my earlier years
feeling like I wasn't enough,
I needed to be better.
So it was also kind of a hot self
improvement project at the same time.
How did you feel you weren't good enough?
Or what were the things
you hoped to improve?
Well,
cause I'm a head case about this stuff,
so this is not a,
this is not me talking
down. Um, in any way. I,
I struggle with a lot of
these, uh, I think issues.
So I'm asking this as much
for myself as anyone else.
Yeah, yeah. Well, um,
I've come to call it the trance
of unworthiness in retrospect. Um,
and I, I, I like talking about it cause I,
I feel like most everyone,
I know it's,
it feels like a pervasive suffering in
our culture that we have this sense that
we should be better, that
we're, you know, there's a,
there's a cartoon I love with this dog
on a psychiatrist's couch. Anything,
it's always good dog this and good
dog that, but is it ever great dog?
It does, doesn't it? Yeah.
So, so, um, I text her myself.
I was,
um,
I think the biggest areas of feeling
unworthy or not good enough was a sense of
being selfish or self centered.
Like in some way my own needs come first.
Then also ceiling.
I remember in high school and first years
of college being out of control with
my eating and feeling
overweight and being really,
really ashamed of that. So
I felt that was, you know,
something is wrong with me there.
And then I just in some
way was falling short,
whether it was as a friend
or a daughter or whatever.
And I had a lot of insecurity about
and I would just very driven to seek.
And so I could see the different
ways that it played out. But, um,
it was definitely the core
sense of I'm not good enough.
And that,
that really became the seed of writing
radical acceptance was both through my
own experience of not enough.
And then as a psychologist
and as a spiritual teacher,
just seeing the torment,
like how many people are not
able to enjoy their moments.
Cause in some way there's a
sense of something's wrong.
And I'll share with you one
story that really hit me. Um,
and I think it's in radical acceptance
of a woman who was in a coma and her
daughter was by her daughter told
me this story and she was dying.
And at one point she,
her kind of eyes bolted
open and she looked at her
daughter in the eye and said,
you know, all my life, I thought
something was wrong with me.
And then she closed her eyes and that
was it. That was her last word. She,
she died after that. And for my
friends for this young, for the woman,
it was kind of a parting gift
because she realized just how,
um,
how sad it is to spend so many
moments at war with ourselves.
And, and, and part of when I teach
about the trance of unworthiness,
we can start to see how,
if we're really not trusting ourselves,
if we're filled with self doubt,
it's very hard to feel
intimate with other people. Um,
there's always a sense that,
yeah, it's like they'll find out.
It's like if I'm right now talking to
you and I feel like there's this core
deficiency,
it means I won't be able to
be spontaneous or, you know,
respond with tenderness.
It's like there's always a defendant mess.
So anyway,
that's a long way around saying that,
that that became very clear
to me. Um, and, and you know,
at the end of college and then
beginning of living in an ashram that,
that I really wanted to, in some
way, I needed to be friend myself.
That became a very clear thing. It wasn't,
it wasn't just a psychological thing.
It's very much a part of
spiritual awakening that I,
that I needed to really be friend.
This life.
When you were having this Ostrom
experience, when did things change?
When did you leave the room?
You know, I was the Ashram, the
strengths and the positive aspects where,
you know, it made it very easily to
have a very regular strong practice.
And you had, the Nice thing
about having group of people,
and I really recommend this to
all of us, is that it's, you know,
to periodically be able to practice with
other people and exchange what's going
on.
That sense of community
can keep on nourishing and,
and enlivening, uh, what's
going on in terms of awakening.
And the Ashram had a lot of rigidity
to it. Tim, it was, you know,
I joined when I was 21 and I came from
this very kind of liberal background.
I was very independent and yet I joined
something that had quite a hierarchy.
It was very patriarchal.
It was really very different from
what I would have thought for myself.
And gradually those qualities as
the kind of rigidity just made it.
So I needed to continue
on the spiritual path,
but not inside the mushroom
environment. So I laughed. Right.
Um,
I left,
I stayed for 10 years and
I had an arranged marriage.
Is that something that's not so
difficult in the last, you know,
I too have, you know, had
all the normal learning to,
you know,
fall in love and prince in shining armor
and get married and instead I, you know,
I was assigned to my husband and, um, um,
I don't know if I should
speed over that one or not.
Uh, you know, we might, I
might come back to that.
You can please continue and then
we might come back to that. Okay.
Um, so, you know, so I went along
with a lot of stuff because,
you know,
again,
I was having very intense altered states
of experience that were very lovely and
it's learned to concentrate
my mind and you know,
had a lot of devotional
experiences and so on, but the,
but the structure and the
authoritarianism of the,
of the community got to me. And, um, so,
so I left after 10 years and,
um,
and then right after leaving
got pregnant and had my son Ryan
and is,
if you wouldn't mind that them,
there's one particular story about
the honest truth. I mean this, this,
this being called out, uh, Oh
yeah, group setting that I think,
I mean it really struck me as
a turning point perhaps where, uh,
an important event at the very least,
if you wouldn't mind
describing that. Uh, yeah.
Add some context as well.
Sure, sure. Um, yeah. Are,
I had been trying to get
pregnant, you know, and,
and really eager to have a child.
And I finally got pregnant and I
went to a gathering, you know, we,
we would gather for about
a month in the mountains.
And I remember it was very,
very hot and it was very
rigorous activity at our,
our gatherings.
And I miscarried.
And so I wrote a note to the
spiritual leader of the community,
um, and, and basically said, you know,
we might want to warn some people
that if you're pregnant this,
you're in this kind of heat and this,
you know, it might not be a good idea.
And I think that that must have made
him feel like I was saying, well,
your teaching something about your
teachings caused me to Miss Kerrick.
And which of course was saying,
but,
but I was in a group of several hundred
people when he had me stand up and he
said,
you know,
you're trying to blame your miscarriage
on such and such and you miscarried
because of your ego.
And he was very,
it was very crude and very,
it was abusive.
It was an abusive behavior to here I
was two days after a miscarriage too.
Um, you know, have me in
that vulnerable a place,
uh, be rated and that way. And so that,
and I'm glad you brought it
up because that, you know,
I had already had a lot of
misgivings about Ostrom living,
but his behavior made it
utterly clear to me that,
you know,
I couldn't be part of something where the
leader with treat people in an abusive
way.
And interestingly,
I have had no abuse or trauma on
that of any real sort in my history.
I think if I had already been an abused
person and I'd already had trauma in my
nervous system,
that it would have been much more
difficult for me to process that.
But as it happened,
um,
after that experience
for the hours after it,
I remember going into a little,
um, kind of a chapel and,
and crying deeply, you know, the
humiliation of it, the pain of it,
heard of it, that kind of the
betrayal. Like how could somebody,
I'd kind of trusted,
do that.
And then I got to a place where either
I became very clear to me that either I
was going to in some way believe that
he knew something and use it against
myself,
or I was going to absolutely get behind
myself in the sense of really dedicate
to embracing myself,
not to buy into some badness because it
could've easily played into the trance
of unworthiness. It could have
been, it could have been the killer,
could have been the nail to the coffin.
And,
but what it made clear to me is
that I really want, you know,
that it was intrinsic to the spiritual
path to trust and embrace the life that's
here. And that doesn't mean to him
that I felt like I, my ego, that I was,
you know, ego free and that I didn't
make mistakes. And you know, I mean I'm,
I'm very,
very aware of all my imperfections.
It more meant that on some fundamental
level was going to trust my goodness.
And so it was a turning point because it
was after that betrayal that I chose to
really, I really committed myself
to accepting myself as I was. And,
um,
since then I ran into this a
quote from Carl Rogers who says,
you know,
it wasn't until I accepted myself just
as I was that I was free to change.
I'm glad you brought that
up. I was actually going to
bring up that exact quote.
Oh really?
And we'll get to that just because
I've found it very challenging and I've
talked to many friends about this,
the balancing of acceptance
versus productivity or the
acceptance versus being
proactive.
And we'll come back to that because I
know this is something you've thought
about before,
but uh,
the Ostrom then at that point is,
is a closed chapter of sorts.
So you embrace,
decide to do what many people perhaps
would not have done because of their
background or circumstances,
which is really sad.
And you see this a lot
in closed communities,
but you took the path
of sort of accepting,
trying to accept yourself as opposed
to accept this a negative version of
yourself that had been reinforced by this,
this leader at that point.
Where did you go with your,
your studying and end or your teaching?
I left. I had been doing a lot of
teaching while I was in the Ashram,
Yoga and meditation.
And I laughed and got very drawn.
My meditation kind of started shifting
and I got very drawn to Buddhist
meditation,
which interestingly is,
if you think of a lot of the
yoga meditations is a very, um,
very much of a training and concentration.
And I,
I suspect we'll get more into the
different kinds of meditation as we speak,
but it,
it can really allow you to quiet
the mind and settle the mind and,
and have access to
experiences of a lot of peace.
And, um, it's, it can be very, very, uh,
very profoundly pleasurable.
And the, and I love that,
but what it didn't teach
me was mindfulness,
which was really how to open up
into the present moment with a,
with a very kind of profound quality of
just simple acceptance and presence to
really notice what's going on right here.
So I got drawn to Buddhism because that,
that capacity for mindful presence,
uh,
became more and more what drew me.
So after I left the Ashram,
I started reading and then
going to retreats. Um,
that were,
that were Buddhist meditation
retreats and they also had a child.
So it was, I was juggling juggling
a few different worlds there,
but they came together.
Okay.
And since I promise to come back
to it and arranged marriage,
I'd like to talk about this because,
and I want to hear your thoughts
on a couple of things, but uh,
so I've had conversations half jokingly,
not totally jokingly with friends who
are say Indian and who have friends,
who've had arranged
marriages and some of these,
these friends live in say New York City
and they have this paradox of choice
conundrum where whoever they're dating
however smart or attractive or kind and
so on,
they might be,
they are passing so many people in the
street that they worry might be just a
little more attractive, a little
more of this, a little more that,
that they hop from one person to
the next to the next to the next in
relationships. And they will, if
I have a few drinks with them,
sometimes they'll joke,
you know,
it'd be a lot easier if I just had an
arranged marriage because it would take
the decision making out of it
on some level. Or you know,
perhaps my parents could say,
not this is the one person,
but here are the five people
you have to choose from.
They're all really great
people. Take your pick. And I,
I'd just love to hear how your arranged
marriage was arranged. Like what,
what were the criteria?
How will,
how were you two paired and
just your general thoughts on,
uh,
on that entire experience.
Yeah. So maybe just to make a
broader comment that, you know,
for some people from some traditions,
it may well be that,
you know,
given a handful of people that there
may be somebody in that handful that it
really does work better for them.
And so it's Mrs not like a judgment
that culturally this is a bad,
a bad ritual, you know. But, um,
and in this particular
case, um, it happened,
I'd say a good number of times,
maybe three quarters of the
marriages of the, you know,
we were all in our twenties when we first
joined the ash from were arranged by
the head of the whole
organization. And, um,
and,
and so mine was,
and it was not done by any criteria
that any of us could ever think of.
It was very much that,
um, he, there was a,
a man who lived in Canada and needed
his green card. That's what it was.
And they want to end,
he was part of our larger community and
they wanted him to be able to move into
the country and get a green card.
And so they were looking for somebody
to match them with and they knew I was
single and they, they made the
arrangement for me not only to marry him,
but I had to leave where I was living,
which was Boston and come down to,
so it was,
it seemed in my mind to be absolutely
this crazy groundless pairing.
I couldn't imagine.
I mean,
it was just so far from what
I ever imagined for myself.
And when I met him,
he was a perfectly nice person,
but very,
very far from anybody.
I would have naturally in my own
choosing have picked as a mate.
So it was, it was really, really rough.
I was very upset by it.
I pleaded not to have to do it.
And ultimately it was my sense that well
to be dedicated to this path means to
be,
to go along with this.
That was somehow or rather how my mind
construed at that I needed to surrender.
I needed to surrender my wants and,
and just do it.
And I'm still,
and I can say right now and my current
state of mind kind of astonished that I
would have viewed it that way because
as I say, I came up from a very,
I came at a pretty independent thinking
people, but that's what happened.
And I married him and it turned out
that he was, as I said, a very, uh,
you know,
a wonderful,
wonderful human and he considered
continues to be a dear friend and brother.
I mean, he really is. He's very, we're
very much, we had a child together. We,
even though we divorced,
we co-parented and we're good friends.
And I think Tim, that, you know,
part of it is because we didn't fall in
love in a romantic way when we decided
to divorce.
There wasn't the kind of um,
painful tearing apart that
brings up so much, you know,
anger and census of betrayal and so on.
We were able to,
we were able to move on together.
Yeah, you didn't have the right
word, but you didn't have that.
A lot of the components that
create the complexity and sort of,
I suppose one could say to
irrational anger and exaggerated, uh,
anger directed at the other
person just didn't exist.
Exactly. I mean, the
more attachment there is,
the more the fallen that when we come
apart, the more, you know, pain and,
and feeling of, you know, vengefulness
and everything flies up. So no,
it didn't have that.
So I'd love to talk about meditation
and mindfulness and we'll get to that
looking at the different
types of meditation.
But I'd love to ask you a
couple of questions that are
just on my mind right now.
So you mentioned enjoying the d,
The desires,
the sex, the drugs, the this, the that,
which all sounds pretty fun quite frankly.
Uh,
is it possible to be a mindful hedonist?
And if so,
is that a bad thing?
Mindful sheepness
that should be my next
one. Fuck. I like it.
I think it's possible to take
tremendous pleasure in this world.
In fact, you know, when one teacher says,
why six sate your desire on one thing,
I'm not just desire it all.
And,
and the more we're in that kind of
receptivity where there's just an amazing
appreciation for the simplest
things for everything. Um,
actually there's a lot of freedom in that
because there's not a lot of clenching
and holding on and having to control
where the idea of mindful hedonism could
fall on its face is if we become
attached to the particular current,
if he didn't as him being a
certain way. So, you know,
if we become attached to always
having a certain food and then it,
and then we ended up getting addicted
or we get attached to a certain chemical
substance and it then becomes harmful
for our body or we take hedonistic
pleasure and dealing
with one person sexually,
but then it turns out that it
doesn't work out with that person.
So if you see what I mean when there's
attachment and it's a tight holding,
it actually causes a sunburn.
Totally,
totally agreed.
I have a friend who
uses hedonistic as this.
He says it was the sort of bitter
cutting edge to his voice is a very close
friend. I won't name them,
but I think that it's, it's a,
it's kind of got a bad rap.
I mean, not to say that, uh,
that everyone should aspire to be. He
knows. But I think that there's a, also,
from,
from my own experience at least,
and just looking at modern
technologically enabled culture,
there is a, there appears
to be a disconnect, uh,
where a lot of human beings do not
know how to enjoy a sensual pleasures.
And by that I don't mean purely
sex. Like they don't, they don't,
they don't feel at home in their own
bodies. They don't walk around barefoot.
They don't have these types of sensory
experiences that it can be so rich.
Uh, and uh, that's,
I feel like the baby just kind of gets
thrown out with the bath water a lot.
And I'd be curious to hear how you might
recommend someone experience pleasures
without developing a harmful attachments.
For instance,
before we started recording,
I was chatting with you a little
bit about fasting and, uh,
I've been experimenting with
fasting partially just to
prove to myself that I am
self sufficient and conserved
five fasting. I mean, it's a very,
it's been a very empowering
experience for me. And, uh,
similarly I did an experiment with
my audience a few months ago, um,
called Knob nom,
which I got a lot of grief for,
but it meant a no booze,
no masturbation for 30 days.
And so we had about 10,000 people do this
experiment and it was very empowering
for everyone involved. Even those
who didn't make it the full 30 days.
But aside from these intermittent
periods of abstinence sees experiments.
So there are other ways or practices that
help someone not develop attachment to
uh,
I suppose anything but certain pleasures
certainly would fall in that category.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a wonderful question because
really if we look at our lives, um,
where they're suffering, if we're
not happy and if we're not at home,
it's really because of the sense
of I want things different.
I want more. There's not enough
here. And that's attachments.
Like I have to have more. It's
have to have feeling. And so,
um,
my experience is that the more we actually
are in the moment and in the census,
like right here,
right now,
the more we decondition grasping.
So the very training of cause
this grass when it comes,
like you have something and then you have
the idea that you need to have more to
be happy.
But if you actually let go of the
idea and just experience directly,
contact the center, the pleasure in
the moment, and just notice that.
And then if there's this arising
of a sense of wanting more,
you just notice that and then you
come back right to your body. Again.
It's staying in the moment that actually
interrupts the chain reaction that
leads to grasping on to things.
But that takes practice them.
I mean it's like for most people,
as soon as we have the first
few spoons of ice cream,
um,
it's kind of like we forget and we just
spoon it in and we don't taste until at
the end there's something lingering
and then we have to have more.
And there's already,
we're already leaning into the future.
So to stay with each bite,
there's actually a fulfillment in it and
we don't go down that track of having
to have.
Right. And it's, it's, uh,
I'm glad you mentioned the,
the eating. Um, my girlfriend
has done, as I mentioned before,
we get started, a
massive fan of yours, uh,
has done quite a bit with
women with eating disorders.
And I know you spent a lot
of time thinking about this,
but she's had a lot of success with
her past clients simply saying,
you're allowed to eat
whatever you want to eat,
but you have to really enjoy it and focus
on the experience of eating that food.
And just by not forcing,
but facilitating that.
A lot of those people didn't
go on autopilot and consume
the 12th scoops instead
of one, for instance. And, uh, the,
the, um, she's trying to stop me from
drinking wine last night and she said,
you're allowed to have another glass,
but I want you to think about it.
At first I was like, oh,
you got me. Uh, anyway,
but the, uh, it was a very nice
sons here in, in, in my defense.
But the, yeah, I'm, I'm getting, I'm
going off the rails here. Let me,
let me steer my, my, uh, my
thinking back on track. Um,
one of the challenges that I have
is, uh, for instance, anger. Uh,
this is, I've, I've been rewarded
in life for a lot of, I feel,
uh, aggression, sort of bull
in a China shop type of,
uh,
aggression sounds very,
has a negative connotation,
but being, being very,
very proactive with trying to accomplish
the things that I set out before me,
whatever those things might be.
And a,
maybe a side effect of that is a lot
of anger directed at myself directed at
other people. And I'd love for
you to talk about it. This was,
this was something that I just really,
when I talk about radical acceptance,
this is one of the examples I bring up,
or one of the stories.
Could you talk about Maura
and inviting Mara to tea?
I'd love to be, can I ask you a
question about the anger? Sure. Yeah.
Do you feel like it causes you suffering?
And if so,
how do you notice it as suffering?
Because I get that you've
gotten rewards for aggression.
Yeah. Uh, and, and I'm not, the
answer is yes, absolutely suffering,
which is part of the reason that,
that I finally started attempting to
meditate regularly and I've done a fairly
good job, uh, was because I
recognize the suffering was not,
not only undesirable on so many levels,
but unsustainable. I
mean, it was, it was, uh,
and I'm not the person who came up with
this, this was analogy, but, uh, the,
you know,
the acid hurts the vessel that is storing
it more than anything that it happens
to be poured upon.
And I was just carrying around this acid
all the time and I recognized it wasn't,
it wasn't a sustainable, um, it
wasn't sustainable in any way.
So yes, definitely suffering. Uh,
I'm never good enough for myself
ever. Uh, for instance, I mean, I end,
and this is,
this is where I have so much trouble
because I won't mention names here,
but for I'll give you just the type of
anecdote that on one hand people could
say is ridiculous. On the other hand,
I really enjoy, and maybe this is,
you can read into my pathology
here. Uh, so there, there,
there's a very famous tech entrepreneur
who is a billionaire several times over
and he was playing chess with
a very well known competitor.
One point and this billionaire lost.
And he stood up and swiped all the pieces
off the board and kind of stormed off.
And the other guy said, wow, you're
really, you're really bad at losing.
And he said, show me a good loser
and I'll show you a fucking loser.
And now that's a very,
uh,
that's a very exaggerated example perhaps.
But I mean, if you look at some of my
favorite movies, right? Like miracle,
which is a Disney movie, but
it's amazing. It's about the,
the US hockey team when they,
they were the,
I think expected to be number 16th or
17th and made it all the way to the gold
medal match against the Soviets, who at
the time were thought to be invincible.
And just the,
the,
the extreme nature of the training and
the pushing and how hard they had to push
to even make that remotely possible
is attractive to me. Right?
And so as a competitor, and I'm going
on a little long winded it bit here,
but I was always taught and in fact maybe
I just taught myself that like second
place is first loser,
right?
Like I would rather be last place than
second place because second place means
you tried really, really, really, really
hard but just not hard enough. You,
you tried like 2% less than the person
who got the gold metal metal and no one
remembers the silver medalist ever.
So
let me ask you a question about that then.
If you had a step back
and look at your life,
what is the most important place that
you would want to win a gold medal?
I mean, if you really think at the
end of your life, looking back,
if you could be the
very best in something,
it's just like what?
What do you most want to be best at?
I would say,
um,
creating learners who
are better than I am.
And if I do that,
I feel like I can create a benevolent
army of part you tens of thousands,
maybe hundreds of thousands,
maybe millions of world class teachers
and that just self replicates.
So I think that would be the answer one.
I know we're bouncing around here,
but it's okay. The one of the,
when I started meditating
regularly for the first time,
it was only because I had two people I
could identify with recommended to me
when I was really in a very to dark
places. So one was chase Jarvis,
who's a world class photographer.
He's been on this podcast
and other was Rick Rubin,
legendary music producer who
also has been on this podcast.
And in this particular case,
and we'll get into the different
types of meditation. They said,
why don't you try TM?
Okay,
so transcendental meditation and because
these two guys did not strike me as
very woo woo or overly detached
from the stresses I faced,
does that make sense?
Like they were negotiating contracts,
they were dealing with difficult people.
They were really on the front
lines of their own respective wars.
If you want to look at it that
way. And so I was like, okay,
if they're recommending this thing that
I've kind of discarded as a not a fit
for me. Right. I, I've,
I've always shied away from using
the word spiritual for instance.
But because it came from these two
people, I decided to give it a shot. The,
and then I started seeing the
benefits of meditation. I mean,
even if I just looked at it through the
lens of my type a personality full of
ambition and Piss and vinegar and
self flagellation, I was like,
if I meditate in the morning,
I get more done with less
stress and others less flailing.
So for that reason, for that reason
alone, I don't meditate. Right.
Uh,
and then I remember getting to a point
after meditating for the first time ever
in my life consistently for about, I don't
know, let's, let's call it two weeks.
I was,
I was on a road trip with a friend of
mine who had had a very similar experience
and, and uh, she asked me,
do you ever worry that
you're getting to chill,
that you are losing your edge,
that you're not doing things you should,
you should because you're too
accepting of whatever happens as being,
okay. Uh, so I struggled with
that. I know we're, we're, uh,
we're digging in here, but,
uh, that, that balancing of
enjoying the benefits of meditation and
how much I would say happier I am and
how much more content I am when I meditate
regularly with the nagging concern
that perhaps I've taken
it too far and I'm,
I've just become
lackadaisical or complacent.
And when I talk to my friends who
are like world class performers,
type a personalities, they all have
this kind of this concern, right?
Like what if I lose my edge? Right? Like,
what if I lose the thing that
has allowed me to be the top,
you know, in the top 5% in my field
as opposed to an also ran. And I mean,
I just love to hear your thoughts on
that because this is something that, uh,
that, uh, it hasn't stopped me from
meditating because I feel like it,
that's my medication on some level too,
to keep me from not being a huge pain in
the ass to myself and everyone around.
Well,
how about this?
Here's the way that I think is
that I like to frame it is that
meditation is evolution strategy
to bring out our full potential.
Well, I like that. Okay.
And just the way we know we need to still
exercise to maximize our body's health,
we need to mentally trained too.
And so meditation's very broad.
You know, there are many
different kinds of meditations,
but a training of the,
I'll call it the heart mind,
really what it does in
a very specific way.
This is what research is showing is it
activates a part of the frontal cortex
where there's kind of neurocircuitry
that really has to do with, um,
being able to have a larger perspective,
being able to have better
executive functioning,
being able to have more empathy,
being able to have more compassion.
And it started evolving in the
human species. You know, we,
it's what led us form tribes and be
able to start collaborating more.
And it's a collaboration that's actually
allowed us to have the greatest of the
scientific kind of breakthroughs
and so on. So if you look at it,
and then in terms of
evolutionary development,
both your own evolution
and also as a species,
the more that we learn
to direct our attention,
the more we have access to what's
called like a whole brain thinking,
where we really can be creative, where
we really can be spontaneous. We,
it's almost like it evolves.
So this past the identification with a
separate cell into something more whole.
And I think often of all this actually
describes this reducing valve of
awareness where in the EGOIC state the
mind just takes in the information so we
can, you know, survive and do
our, our daily functions. And it,
it kind of blocks out a lot of the
vast mysteries of the universe.
And as we meditate that reducing
valve doesn't reduce so much.
So we actually have more of the flow
of a kind of universal intelligence.
And creativity that moves through us.
So I do think of it that this training
actually can allow us to access our
greatest potential.
Now here's a couple of pieces
to it that in the egoic state,
dominance and competition are
really the way to a flourishing.
And so those people not familiar
with the term, the EGOIC state,
it's just the focus on I
yes,
yes it did.
It's very self focused so that we're
doing things so that we can, um,
I can be the basket,
I want to be recognized because I want
to be special because I'm an important
person.
So it's that kind of thing.
Sounds like my writing.
I'm kidding.
And
when you think of the moments when
you're happiest, it may give you an,
we might get an initial rush of chemicals
when we feel personally recognize and
personally the baster.
I know I wrote in my most recent book,
my special person complex. You know,
where I get caught and you know,
feeling important in some way.
And yet that's not when we're happiest.
In fact, you know, the way that you
can sense and an evolutionary way.
So we are as a species learning
to identify with larger,
wider and wider circles of beings
were able to feel a sense of,
as you and I talked that it's not
me proving something are impressing,
but it's, there's some collectivity
that's going on between us.
It's creating an entirely new field.
I could not agree more and also
to speak more cause I've had
a lot of caffeine. The uh,
the fact of the matter is if I want to
have the impact that I mentioned and to
create hundreds of thousands or millions
of worldclass learners, the most,
the, the more effective way to do
that is by having a team to help me.
So whether whether I'm
collaborating with five people,
10 people or a hundred people or even
fewer potentially having a very short fuse
has been a major handicap for me.
That's exactly the,
that's exactly where I was going.
Is that the thing you most want to
experience and to produce for you,
Tim, is world class learners
and world class teachers,
which I'm imagining if I read into
that with then allow there to be more
creativity, healing and wellbeing.
On the planet earth. Yes,
definitely more and more problem solvers.
So you have no problem solvers who can
also train additional problem solvers,
right? So it becomes this sort of
exactly the Netherlands virus. I,
I mean, maybe that's not
the right phrasing to use,
but a wave of problem solving
that it's hard to contain.
That only happens when we are
operating in a collaborative way.
So what the very,
um,
domain that you are engaged with
is really a more about domain.
It's not the competitive domain.
It's going more towards collectivity,
towards,
um,
belonging to a field and you're working
to wake up to that and engage other
people in it. So, in a way,
when you ask that question,
what will keep my edge? Well,
really the new edge that we want to
keep as our capacity for empathy and
collaboration and mutual creativity.
Right? Right. Yeah. I'm sharpening the,
the hatchet when it's like, no, dude,
you got to sharpen the saw. It's a
different tool. You're spending your talk.
Exactly.
Right.
Interestingly, with
meditation, it doesn't,
what it does is it actually serves
that you become better at that.
Yeah. I've, uh, I,
I've been really profoundly
affected by a daily practice.
And what I would,
I'd love to do to get granular for people
is to talk about perhaps some thought
exercises or practices that people are
currently working 80 hours a week and
feel like they can't take a lot of time
[inaudible] Tate could utilize and I'm
not, I'm not sure if the sacred pause
is a good one to talk about. Um,
I really enjoyed that discussion.
Um, but could you also,
because I feel like among
my group of friends,
this would be very interesting
for them to contemplate. Could,
can you talk about little exercises
that people could use? Uh,
if they want to not flame out.
And what I mean by that is I know a lot
of type a personalities who are like,
if I'm going to meditate,
I'm going to meditate.
And so they try to block it out like an
hour every morning for like five days a
week. And of course they don't
make it to the end of the week.
It becomes too much. So I'd like
to prevent that, you know, these,
these driven people from
defeating themselves, uh,
which is what I did for a long time. But
the, uh, the inviting Mara to tea, um,
I'd love for you to describe what that is.
Uh,
and yeah,
and then I'll let you run with,
with the discussion
wherever you want to go.
Okay.
So in the Buddhist mythology,
and this is to me one of the most
amazingly contemporary relevant kind of
principles in the universe,
the Buddha's awakening
to a larger reality.
I came through, he sat this night, uh,
under what's called the Bodhi tree.
The vote is the tree of awakening.
And through the night,
the God Mara who represents a anger,
greed, pride, a version,
um, passion, jealousy,
all the,
all the forces that can
take over and create misery.
I packed them and you know,
there were,
so there were arrows and flames of light
and spears and so on coming at them.
And you know,
he sat through the night and practice
this quality of presence so that all this,
the attacks, each of the weapons
turned into a flower petal.
So by the morning, morning
star when it rose, he,
there was a heap of pedals that is at, is,
uh, in front of him. But interestingly,
Mara did not just vanish
and the Buddhist lifetime,
Mara would keep appearing and so huge,
the Buddha would be teaching
in a field somewhere.
A lot of people gathered and Mara would
start lurking in the outskirts and the
Buddha's loyal attendant would be
freaked out and they'd say, Oh my God,
Mara is here. What are we
going to do? The shadow is com,
but the Buddha would kind
of say, chill. It's okay.
And then what do you do is go right
tomorrow and say, I see you Mara. Come,
let's have tea.
And what those two
communications really say.
I see you, Mara is mindfulness.
You know, I see you.
I get in this moment what's happening?
Okay, there's fear, there's anger.
It's so this,
this capacity.
We each have to pause and just
recognize this is what's here right now.
It's an honest recognition.
So he said, I see you Mara.
And that's considered the first wing
of presence, seeing what's here.
And then the second come,
let's have tea is instead of
fighting what's here in the moment,
there's making space for it.
There's getting to know it.
There's a quality of heart.
It's the quality of heart space that
lets the life be just as it is in the
moment.
And these two wings of presence that
you see in this myth really are the very
foundation of a meditation practice
that in any moment that we can pause and
say, you know, you can ask that question.
So what is happening inside me right now?
And I invite all of you who are
listening to this right now just to,
you might just check in what is
happening inside me right now.
Okay?
I check the feelings in your body
sensations. If there's a mood,
this is the first wing of
mindfulness that we say, okay,
so here's what it's like right now,
Mary, with our senses, very embodied.
And then the second win,
which is let's have tea,
is really like a thing.
I'm just going to allow how
this experience is right
now to be just as it is
with amber brings some interest and
some care to it. Let's have tea.
So it's a way of being with
ourselves that's intimate,
that's full and naturally it extends.
Cause if you can say to yourself,
okay, here's what's happening,
there's some anxiety and
okay, let me be with that.
Then when you run into another person
and they are aggravating and you in some
way and judgment comes up or they're
intimidating you, you could say,
oh okay, so this is Mara
again. Um, I see you Mara,
and you're saying this to yourself.
I,
I get that this is intimidating and
let's talk to you. So there's a,
you create a space of
presence for what's there.
And in response to what you said earlier
is couldn't this be passive or kind of
a, a chill stance? Um,
it's really out of that presence that
we can then act in a way that is most
intelligent and most empowered.
So this one radical presence and radical
acceptance that I'm describing these
two wings of what's going on and let's
have tea that's not are permanent stance.
That's the grounds for action.
It's like we've come home into the moment,
we've come into some
stability and balance,
and then when we respond to the world,
we actually are responding
from our full potential.
We're not in a reactive mode.
We have our internal house in
order. I mean it's, we have,
that's exactly
right. Yeah. We've, we've,
we've, we've Rican, you know,
we're online again in a way because what
happens is when we're reacting to the
world,
we kind of cut off from some of the
parts of our frontal cortex that actually
can make us most effective.
And I'll give you an example.
A story that that's always touched me of
this is a surgeon or commanding
surgeon in the army who took us,
took an anger management course. So this
does is, this has to do with anger down.
And you took this course and it
was very much based on mindfulness,
based on what is happening in this
moment. And can I open to this? Okay.
So he took the course because
she was ordered to actually and
yeah, yeah, yeah. And um, and he,
and then as the story goes, he went the
end of the day to a supermarket to um,
you know,
cause he need this so up on supplies and
he gets into line and in front of him
as a woman with just a few items
in her cart. And not only that,
um, she's got a baby and it isn't,
this is not the express line.
And so we start fuming cause why
does she get into express line?
She's in front of me and taking time.
She has the baby to the clerk and they
are laying and I know over this little
girl and so he is okay.
So he is triggered and he
remembers mindfulness. Okay.
The first step with my phone,
cause you pause and that's a sacred pause.
She sense, okay, something's
going on, let's pause.
And then the second step is, okay, so
what's going on inside me right now?
You know, what are we
seeing? And He, you know,
so he noticed it was anger and then he
could feel underneath the anger that
anxiety.
And many of us know the anxiety of when
we're busy and on our way and it feels
like a whole world's going to fall apart
cause we're going to be late or not
prepared.
So he could censor his anger
and fear underneath the anger.
And then as she had to with it,
as he just stayed with it,
he found some more space
and some more presence.
So when he looked up and he saw the
little girl, I thought, oh, she's cute.
And when it was his turn, the
woman had left with, with the girl.
He said to the clerk, you know
that that little girl was adorable.
And the clerk beamed at him and she said,
Oh thank you.
Actually that's my little girl.
My husband was killed in Afghanistan
last year and my mom brings,
sure by everyday, twice a day so we
have a little time together. Wow.
Yeah.
I share that story because if we
don't pause and deepen attention,
we live out patterns.
We've been living our whole lives.
To keep us separated from ourselves,
our highest self and each other.
And you know, we don't know what's
going on for others. You know,
it's not like everybody has
just endured that kind a loss,
but not everybody's struggling hard.
And we're so quick to,
to take personally into
read our lives into things,
to be able to pause and both bring
mindfulness and attention inwardly.
And then outwardly this is,
this is what's going to change the world.
This is what's gonna allow us to
step out of reactivity that tools,
wars and actually be more collaborative.
This is evolution.
I really appreciate that story also
because it brings to mind for those people
out there who are struggling with some
of the same things as this, uh, the,
the gent in the story or, you know, the,
the kinds of things that I, I'm very,
uh,
sometimes the anger very often takes
the form of impatience or maybe it's the
other way around. I'm not sure.
But, uh, very impatient and, uh,
generally always have been. I mean,
ever since I was a little kid, if,
if I sat with an empty water glass in
a restaurant and my mom thinks this is
hilarious,
but also kind of annoying,
I would just like get up and walk into
the kitchen and grab a pitcher of water,
like not known for by my patients.
And there are benefits to that sometimes.
Uh,
but the,
what I started doing a few years ago,
and in fact what I think helped prime
me for meditation is reading quite a bit
of stoic philosophy, uh, which,
which I think has a lot in common with
certain types of Buddhism or teachers,
teachings of Buddhism. Anyway, but
a couple of things really helped me.
The first was,
uh,
trying in the morning to basically do it.
Marcus are released it.
So Marcus are really as who wrote
meditations, but it was really a,
basically a journal.
There was never intended for publication
was at one point the most powerful man
in the world. And he would wake up, and
this sounds depressing to some people,
but I don't find it depressing. And he
would say, you know, today I am going to,
and I'm paraphrasing, but run into
people who are ungrateful, rude,
entitled,
et Cetera.
And basically I sh I need to be prepared
for that and not overreact to it.
And along the same lines,
you know,
in the mornings when I've tried to remind
myself of when I Journal at usually
after meditating is you know,
everyone is fighting a battle.
You know nothing about number one. And
then number two, and I think this is,
this was extremely important for me
and I can't remember who told me this
initially,
but it was don't ascribe to malice
what can be explained by incompetence.
And I actually added
to that and I was like,
don't ascribe to malice what can be
explained by incompetence or dizziness.
Right. And I mean I'm, I'm
amazed sometimes, and I know
I've done this in the past,
but when somebody will come up to me,
I've never met them before my life,
and they'll say, you didn't respond to my
email. I'm like, I don't know your name.
I don't know who you are.
I have no idea what you're talking about,
but they're overreaction to that.
You know,
assuming that I had sort of slighted
them by reading the email and siding,
it was unimportant and the ignoring it,
which was not the case at all,
his guarantee,
virtually guaranteed that I will not
respond to there cause I got so pissed off
and flew off the handle and I have no idea
what their name is in the first place.
Uh, but what, what are Le,
let's look at a couple of
different types of meditation.
I'd love for you to sort of describe,
actually, let me, let me take a step back.
Let's talk about your personal experience.
So what does your,
what does the first 60 to 90
minutes of your day look like?
Your morning routine?
Well, I am woken up if I don't wake up
myself, I get up real early. I mean,
I actually wake up around, well not
real early, that five or so, five 30,
but if I don't pop out of bed,
then I've got a dog that will climb on
my chest and licked my face and nudged me
out of bed.
Um,
and so he does that because we
go right away straight from,
uh, we go right down to the river.
I live right by this Tomic River.
So usually hike for about three
to four miles in the morning.
It's the first thing with my dog
and it's almost any weather. Um,
I was think that, no breakfast,
no coffee, Yay. Yeah,
go out. I just leave cause I
find for myself, um, I like, um,
I've always been very physical and um,
so and when I was younger,
more athletic and that's a whole other
story because I did lose it for a while.
But,
um,
I find that for me just moving and
moving vigorously and being in nature is,
you know, if I had to say what my religion
is, it's, you know, being in nature,
I just love it. So, you know,
so we go and we do is kind of
up down hike and by the river,
by the river and in the hills.
And then about an hour into the hike,
I have a place by a stream that I'll
stop and then I'll do a meditation there.
So I do a standing
meditation there and uh,
could last anywhere from 20 to 45 minutes
and then we do the rest of the hike
and I come home.
What does that standing meditation,
uh,
what, what is that comprised of? Uh,
what does it consist of?
Like said, so when you,
if you could just walk us through what
that standing meditation is sort of
internally, what the, what you're
focusing on and not focusing on et cetera.
Sure. And, and any one of the component,
the first part is really pausing.
It's like getting that, ah,
okay. I just stopped this forward
motion that's like we have,
we always have the sense that
we're on our way somewhere.
So there's really a sense of,
okay,
I'm pausing to be right here and that
this moment matters as much as any moment
in the whole universe because we tend to,
we tend to think that this
isn't what's important.
It's yet to come or it's back there.
So to really just pause,
and there's a beautiful
quote from Viktor Frankl.
It says between the stimulus,
the response, there's a space.
And in that space is your
power and your freedom.
So that, that's the beginning. It's just
getting, okay, pausing and arriving,
open or closed.
Well, sometimes I'll start open
and really taken the, you know,
I'm right by a stream and right
now there's, you know, incredible,
you know, the birds and the sounds of
the currents and everything. It's uh,
it's quite lovely,
but so I'll take it all in,
but of course my eyes eventually
just to kind of quiet my mind more.
So I began very much with a,
a kind of a sweep through
the body with my awareness.
And I will kind of starting
from the head down,
I'll just soften and relax different
parts of my body so that I'm feeling the
life from the inside out.
So I'm feeling a sense of sensation.
So if you're listening and you just close
your eyes and I sometimes will use the
image of a smile to help,
to deepen that sense of presence and ease.
You can sense the eyes smiling.
You can smile into your eyes and feel
the corners of the eyes up a little and
let the brow be smooth.
So there's just a way of softening in the
eyes because when we're thinking a lot,
when we're in that home movie that's
filled with a kind of incessant inner
dialogue and a lot of, a lot
of fear usually or stress, um,
the, the little muscles
around the eyes or tense.
So by softening the eyes and
letting the brow be smooth,
that that actually helps the mind to
quiet some and you can actually put a half
smile on the mouth. And uh, it's amazing.
There's a lot of research on this dude
that if you have a little bit of a smile
and you can feel the inside
of your mouth smiling,
that that actually sends a message
to your whole nervous system too.
You can relax the whole
fight, flight, freeze,
constellation and access more of,
um,
in evolutionary terms it's called attend
and befriend that there's just more of
a benevolent witnessing when there's a
slight smile. So that's another trick.
And again, even if you're not
sitting for a long meditation,
just pausing and closing your eyes and
relaxing the eyes and having a little bit
of a smile itself,
just even a 32nd pause can shift you
from the sympathetic nervous system,
which is really a very defensive and
aggressive to the parasympathetic,
which is much more ease filled.
So I sweep down the eyes the mouth,
I go to the shoulders and
let the shoulders fall away
from my next song so that
I can just soften in the shoulders.
And even again,
as you're sitting,
you might feel the shoulders from the
inside and see if it's possible to have a
little bit of that,
that melting of ice to water.
Okay.
I still water.
And then what are two
gas kind of letting go.
And it's really, really helpful
to let the hands rest in that, um,
very easy,
effortless way because when I have my
hands by my side or if you have your hands
in your lap,
because again,
when we're stressed we have these
micro muscles tense in the hand.
So by consciously softening your hands,
you actually deconditioning that stuff.
Stress Reaction.
This was actually a question
that a number of readers had,
which was sort of like
a Ricky Bobby I think.
And tally tally Talladega
nights knows anchorman.
I don't know what to do with my hands.
I don't have to do with my hands.
They were asking when I'm
sitting in a sitting meditation,
does it matter what you do with your
hands? As long as they're relaxed,
there are literally called Mudras that
are hand positions that in a refined yoga
kind of perspective have energy
circulating a certain way.
But the deeper purpose of practice,
if you're training your
mind to pay attention,
if you just soften and relax your hands,
there'll be a slow and you
won't be perpetuating Kanchan
do you want your hands together?
They can be touching lightly,
but you can also play some palms down
on your right above your knees and just
let it be a light touch there
and just feel the contact,
the warmth, the tangling.
And that's fine too.
Uh,
I've sometimes placed when I'm
sitting with my back straight,
uh, which analysis have a cushion behind
me because I find it too stressful to do
freestanding. But if I,
if I put my arms, this is,
this is gonna sound like probably
the worst idea ever. But when I,
when I sort of sit,
I sometimes sit in a posture that's
similar to what I used to do for a judo
before practice.
They would have you do [inaudible] said
have you do a short meditation before
and afterwards and you basically put your
palms close to the crease in your hip
so that your elbows are just kind
of flared out to the sides a bit.
But for my 20 minute meditation,
I can tell almost the second one,
it's 20 minutes because my
wrist starts to tingle. But, uh,
the, uh, I don't want to interrupt you.
The description of standing meditation,
what are you doing the sweep then for
how long do you do this? Sweet, right?
Hey, what I'm describing, most
people would do this sitting,
this just happens to be me cause I,
I just like being outside when I can,
but everything I'm describing us for
those that are listening sit in a way
where,
you know,
ideally it's comfortable but you could
sit up tall because really you want the
posture to invite forward the
qualities of mind that mattered to you.
So we want to be alert and
we also want to be at ease.
So the idea is sit comfortably but sit
with your spine tall and I would not use
the kind of thing you described him as it.
There's good reasons for judo, but for,
for training and meditation,
let it be more relaxed.
You don't need anything to
adds tension to the body.
Yeah.
So yeah. So if I was going to continue
and I'm not, cause I'm actually,
I realized I was moving right into a
guided meditation, but um, just to,
just a sleep through the body and census
there anywhere they can relax just a
little bit more right now.
And what you'll find is
if you ask that question,
you'll notice that without even
knowing it, the body tenses and it,
and to really relax and relax is really,
really helpful.
And,
and I want to emphasize just a couple
of things that have been helpful for me
and I'd let you feel free
to veto any of these. I'm,
I'm still on training wheels, but, uh,
I know a lot of people out there haven't
even tried to get on the bike with
training wheels. So a few
things. Number one is,
uh, I have, uh,
found that just the sitting
alone has huge benefits,
whether or not I feel I've been able
to quiet my mind in any way. So if I,
if I sit down for 20 minutes
with very upright posture,
sort of imagining like a thread being
pulled from the, the, the crown too,
to lengthen the spine and really try
to float my head into a place over my
shoulders and neck so that it feels
weightless to the extent possible. Uh,
I found so many calming benefits,
postural benefits after
even a week or two.
I've never had so many
compliments on my posture ever.
I've never had compliments about my
posture period in my life cause I'm built
like a monkey and a caveman and wrestle
for too long. So I have terrible posture.
But after a week or two, sort of
having complements my posture and my,
my walking gait and everything had changed
and found tremendous benefits of just
sitting with that upright,
not hunched over a laptop pop posture.
Even if I felt like my meditation was
quote a failure and quote because I was
just running through my to do list
or whatever for 20 minutes, uh,
and unable to turn off that monkey
mind. Uh, so just see that. Um,
what, what would you suggest for
someone just getting started,
who's always been turned off of meditation
for any number of associations they
might have with meditation?
Mindfulness? What,
what is a good place to start?
So for instance,
there's a guy named Bj Fogg has done a
lot of research at Stanford. And if you,
if he wants someone to start flossing,
for instance, regularly, he'll say,
don't start with your whole mouth,
just floss your front teeth.
And he'll give them just the smallest,
uh,
task possible to start building momentum.
And
they, right. And that's the
way we do it too. In fact,
then got a program coming out I
think in January called mindful 40,
which is 40 days.
And you can really,
really get the practice down at and we
do 10 minutes a day and it's five minutes
is some, you know, background and
in five minutes of meditation.
So I'm with you,
Tim.
I think starting with a
commitment no matter what,
every day helps a lot because nature
loves rhythms and you can build a habit
with that kind of, um,
every day practicing.
But here, here, here are
the basic ingredients,
is that it's useful at the beginning
to have a place that's quiet and that
you're not going to get interrupted.
And it's useful to close your eyes
just because that will, you know,
there's less stimuli visually
that stimulates associations.
And it's useful to sit
still for a few minutes.
And know that you're just doing this as a,
this is your evolutionary strategy for
bringing out your best and just a few
minutes of sitting still
and one of my friends says,
you put your Tush on your cushion,
you take what you get.
It doesn't matter what happened.
No, no, just sit there.
Now there are of course all sorts of
very helpful guidelines on how to direct
your attention.
That will help to not only quiet
your mind but wake up your senses.
And one of the things that I most love
about the effect of meditation as I'm
more in my body,
it's like I go through the day and I'm
less in that trance of thinking or I'm
going to kind of that I think of it as a
home movie where I'm just off somewhere
else and I feel more of a liveliness and
energy through my body and at my senses
are more awake.
You know,
I'm worth taking in the colors and
the forms and the sense and so on.
So it is,
you sit still for a few minutes,
come into your body as well as you
can. The breath is a very good, uh,
homebase are anchor if you want to kind
of commonly just kind of be with the
breath and that's it for starters.
And one tips that I think you gave in
radical acceptance that I found very
helpful and it seems like such a, uh,
I wouldn't say trivial, I mean that,
that minimizes it, but it seems it's
had a larger impact than I expected.
So when I've been told in the past like,
focus on your breath and
then when your mind wanders,
just gently bring it back to the breath.
I was like,
what does that mean to gently
bring it back to the breath?
I don't know how to do that.
What specifically are you
asking me to do? And in,
in a few things really helped. Uh,
one for me was focusing on the breath.
I always found it and still
find it very difficult.
I think this is partially
because I'm a chest breather,
but to feel the breath in the stomach.
And I remember someone said,
just focus on the feeling of the breath
on the outer rim of your nostrils.
And I was like, what? And I started doing
that and it really worked well for me.
So focusing sort of on the sensation of
the breath at the very outside of the
nostrils,
I'm inhaling and exhaling.
But the point from radical acceptance
was focusing on the breath.
And sometimes I'll just say like
inhale XL as I'm doing that. Um,
and I'd like to talk about the uh,
the sort of pros and cons of,
of TM in a second. But the, the,
when I would start thinking about
something, whatever it would be a,
and not the breath, I would
just say thinking, thinking,
and then come back to the breath. That
was, that sort of became my queue.
And I think I'm almost certain that
there were examples of that in radical
acceptance, but I don't want to
attribute something to you that if I'm,
if I'm off base, but, but I started
using that throughout the day too.
When I would get angry, my,
my way of, or impatient,
my way of sort of saying Hello
Tamara would just be to say,
hmm, impatient, impatient or angry, angry.
And it was just enough of a
pattern interrupt to allow
me a greater degree of of
of self control and more
like responsiveness,
choosing to respond as
opposed to being reactive.
Exactly. It is in radical acceptance and
it's one of the most important support
strategies. You know, naming are
noting what's going on. It's really,
really helpful.
So with the breath pick wherever the
breath is easiest and most pleasant did
attacked. So for you it might be the rim
of the nostrils is refined enough in yet
distinctive enough and for somebody else
feeling the whole body breathing can be
doing it. And for some people the
breath itself is not a good anchor.
I know people that have had trauma
around breathing and that's not the best
banker.
So listen to sound and sped,
but you're right when the mind
wanders and you want to bring it back,
if you just name what's going on,
if you just name I was thinking or
worrying or planning or fantasizing.
Sometimes you can even name, which is,
you know, we call it the top, top 10 hits,
you know, like went to the top 10 is
going on right now. Okay. You know,
like basically,
you know,
pissed at my partner for not doing
his or her share, whatever it is.
You can name it and if you name it,
and here's the cool thing.
When you name something,
you're not as identified with it and that,
that's the thing, it doesn't
control you as much. There's a,
there's a saying that when
a sham and names a fear,
they have power over it.
So when you name thinking you're
no longer in the cloud of thoughts,
you're opened up to something larger and
then you can choose is just not useful.
Or is it not often?
You know,
most of the time our thoughts are very
habitual and they're fear-driven and they
just perpetuate a sense of being,
you know,
a victim or being at risk or being
endangered or being stressed.
And if you can catch when you're in
one of those flurries and just say, Oh,
thinking, thinking it's,
it creates some space,
you can relax open
again to a bigger world.
Well,
I also,
I was thinking of a quote that I
actually put in four hour work week,
which was named must your fear
be before banish it? You can,
which is of course by Yoda. So if
it's good enough for you, that's good.
That's good. Good, good. Uh, the, the uh,
so sitting for 10 minutes, uh, the way I
actually started it, and I know this is a,
it's probably a terrible bastardization,
but just for those people
who might find this useful,
a friend of mine named Komal Ravi con
actually recommended that I try this
because I was having so much
trouble meditating what I,
in a way that I could use as successful.
Right. And of course in a, in a way,
the people who need to meditate
now can say the most,
but are the people who are obsessed with
doing things everything successfully.
And yet at the same time,
they're the most,
they might be the people most likely
to quit. So. Exactly right. And uh,
I remember I heard someone say,
you know,
if you don't have 30 minutes to meditate,
you need three hours. And I was like,
wow, okay. But anyway, where I
was going with that is he said,
just pick a song you really liked that
puts you into a good mood and focus on
your breath while listening to that
one song first thing in the morning.
Like before you brush your teeth, before
you eat breakfast, but just wake up,
put the earbuds in,
sit up straight and with a good posture
against the wall if need be and just do
that one song that's like
your state queue. And it was,
I've realized that that's not something I,
uh,
it's not something that I use now,
but I found it very helpful to just
break the ice and end, have the,
the sitting down for three minutes,
be the pass fail mark and not
having to jump right into the
deep end and sort of wrangle with,
with my thoughts quite as intensely. I
found that helpful. I know it's a crutch,
but um,
and the Buddhist tradition
they called skillful means.
It's like there are
things that incline us.
And so if the song and climbed you,
I know a woman who kept saying,
I don't have meditator,
don't have time to meditate because she
would rush rush through her morning.
And then she realized that
her medication time as well,
she was boiling water for her
tea and when she poured her cane,
when she drank her tea and that was
going to be her meditation. And she,
if you call it your meditation,
you actually, you know,
this might not be the language you like,
but you create sound quality of
sacredness or specialness or importance or
meaning. And that's helpful.
That starts inclining you. So I,
I go for anything that helps
to move us towards presence.
No, and I, I have no problem
with secretness by the way. Okay.
That one's okay.
I have just such a Weirdo when it
comes to language and definitions. Uh,
well let me,
let me ask just before I go on one of my,
my massive like left turn tangents again,
a transcendental meditation. What,
what are your thoughts on it?
A I n just for what it's worth,
I'm not a ape surest
or militants TM person.
It just happened to be the first
thing that I did consistently,
but I also do quite a lot of
their days or weeks even when I,
I will do what people might consider
the Pasana Meditation. But what,
what do you view as the pros, cons, um,
of say a TM and just,
just to throw it out there?
One of the cons for me is the fact that
in most circumstances people have to pay
whatever it is, 1500 bucks for
basic training and a mantra,
which I think is extremely cost
prohibitive for most folks. And uh,
really had me raise a ton of red flags.
But I found the accountability of having
a four day for lunchtime meetings in a
row to be necessary to get me to
comply to doing the meditation twice,
twice a day for four days.
And so that was the main gift.
It was really having a sunk cost,
which made me feel compelled to do it,
number one.
And number two,
having an accountability,
which I think other people can probably
engineer and a million other ways.
But what, what are you, what
are your feelings on TM?
Well first a lot of people from the old
days found their way into meditation
through TM because it was one of the
earliest and most well known. So just,
you know,
we have many,
many people that practice
mindfulness that started with TM. So,
and there's with every,
I think one of the things I always have
my antennas go up on any particular
style claims that it's the best of the,
okay.
I have, I mean I'm very fundamentalist
about being non fundamentalists.
So you know, it's like that one always
gets to me because I think that different
personalities and temperaments benefit
from different things and clearly for you
having that structure.
So I like the,
I like that there's a
structure for some people.
There's different styles of
that structure. Um, I too,
I offer everything,
all my meditations for free.
And I just feel like this
came to me, you know, it's,
this is given from the universe and
I want to give it back and, and I,
so I like whenever possible ought to have
to charge for something in this domain
of waking up.
So that always,
and I also like that it'd be
very available to populations
that are underserved
or can't afford it.
So that's another piece.
But in terms of the actual meditation
TM is as primarily a concentrative
practice.
You're taking a mantra or a set of
say could words and repeating them and
repeating them. And the benefit of
which is a narrowing of the Lens.
So focus is that actually collects the
attention and the mind gets quiet and
when the mind is quiet,
there can be experiences of bliss and
serenity and peace and so on. So that,
that's what TM does. It gives
you a break from that, uh,
incessant inner dialogue.
And the more you practice it,
the more easily it is to collect the mind.
Now,
there are other ways.
There are other focuses for
concentration other than a TM mantra.
But that that's the way cam works for me.
The limitation is it doesn't allow
you to see into the nature of reality.
And by that I mean it doesn't bring a
kind of presence that allows you to sense
what's actually happening.
Now,
most of our understanding of
reality is conceptual. We, you know,
we have ideas about things and
to really have a, you know,
a clear, penetrating insight,
um, we need to be present.
And Tm doesn't,
it's like it aims the mind at something,
but it doesn't open the attention
so that whatever arises,
you start learning how to be with it.
And to me,
the power and freedom of mindfulness
is you start getting the knack of being
with whatever arises.
And one of the things I'm very aware of
is that most of us are, you know, we,
we were aware of our mortality and
we're tensing against what can go wrong.
And so we go around our day and in some
way there's this tension about what's
around the corner that might
be overwhelming and we're
not always aware of that
tension,
but it stops us from fully savoring and
luxuriating and being creative and alive
in the moment and what train,
what d conditions.
That tension is when we unconditionally
open to the life that's right here and
we don't resist it. And we realized that
wow, there is space for what's here.
Even when it's unpleasant.
Even when we're,
even when we're sensing
a dying of some short,
to me the gift of meditation
is it actually teaches us
how to be with living and
dying. And so I don't, I don't feel that,
I think TM offers a support in
one part of a meditation training,
but it doesn't go the whole way.
What, what, uh, suicides
from your own books,
which I recommend to everyone
listening a few things.
If people want it to start with two or
three of your guided meditations and
they've, they, they viewed themselves as
sort of stubborn,
a driven types,
which, which meditations might
you suggest that they start with?
Well on my website,
there's a a landing page for a guided
meditations and they're all you,
they're all free and they usually are
anywhere from 12 minutes to, you know,
25 minutes and you can start
them. And, and this, you know,
they,
they start off with really guiding us
into presence and then they keep going.
You can even stop them. Um, I
would use one of the featured ones.
Those are the ones that
are most generically useful
but also just play around.
It really helps to have guided meditations
to begin because you'll eventually
internalize, you'll get an inner
meditation teacher, you know, but here,
but hearing it and hearing kind
of a few different versions,
we'll give you a sense of
what works best for you.
Cause sometimes I'll emphasize
how to relax through the body.
And sometimes I'll emphasize how
to really collect with the breath.
And other times, meditations on
self compassion or forgiveness.
So there's a lot of different
styles and types to play with.
And what is your website?
It's Tara brock.com.
Yeah, that's, that's straight and simple.
And I'll put that in the show notes.
Everybody as well as, uh, other
links to resources and so on. The,
uh, do you have, so the rolling stones
have, let's say, satisfaction, right?
Everybody knows satisfaction, they
love it. It's a crowd pleaser.
Are there any of those meditations that
are kind of like your satisfaction?
Are there any,
uh,
are there any the that appear to resonate
with a higher percentage of people
than others?
And of course I'll encourage people to,
people are going to be hopefully
enjoying these for more than one day,
so they can test quite a few. But if
you, if you had to give your, your, uh,
your hits,
what might those be?
Well, the name I've, I
don't remember the names,
but I have featured meditations on the
landing page for guided meditations and
just choose it according to Lens because
there's pretty much the same content in
them. So got it. But the right there
and there, they're easy to find.
And then there's also
the audio talks page,
which gives the kind of background of
understandings and so on that really
helped us to not only start a
practice but and sustain it,
but really bring it into our lives.
Because the big deal, I mean, you know,
everybody talks about sitting practice.
The really the big deal is can you and
I be talking right now and still have
that quality of remembrance where
we're in touch with what matters,
where we're embodied enough so we
can feel feelings. You know, we,
we tend to cut off so,
uh,
habitually in our lives and
as you described earlier,
we're so plugged into so many
different virtual realities that, um,
to me the big challenge and invitation
is can we get more real and alive in our
day unless habituated and less automatic.
And so that's the carryover.
Outside of your own books,
what's,
say two to three books for people who
want to delve further into meditation,
mindfulness, et Cetera, are there any
other books that you would recommend?
Well, Jack Kornfield, who I teach with
a lot and love is a very good friend.
Um,
has a couple of books that are very good.
His is classic is a path with heart.
And the other book that
is is I think wonderful.
I loved Pema Chodron and
Pema Chodron has her,
one of her classics is
when things fall apart.
So those are,
those are two right there that really,
really helped, you know, helped
me guide into the practices and,
and really help heal the heart.
Is, uh, and this is,
this does not have to be specific to
meditation and Buddhism or anything like
that,
but what book have you gifted the most to?
Other people or books
might have to come back to that.
Cause I sometimes I'll just,
I gift the essential roommate,
which is a collection of poetry
that Coleman Barks at, um,
I think is really, really beautiful
or poetry by the poet pace.
So sometimes it'll be poetry books
at all, all gasped. Um, you know,
I really value Eckhart Tolle,
totally his books and I think he's
done a great job. I think I'd just,
Shanti's done fabulously
even more with his, his, um,
audio, you know, his, his talks and
even as books, but it's books, author,
Wonderful Haji Ashanti.
It's a d y, a shanty.
S. H. A. N. T. I
what is Shanti mean because I've,
I've,
I've seen this word pop up quite a lot.
I'm looking it up right here.
Pcs piece. Ah, there we go.
You beat me to it. You'd beat me to
it. All right. Uh, well that's a,
that's a good word. He is, uh, the, the,
the beginning of your day.
We talked about the,
the hike first thing with the
dog, the standing meditation. Uh,
and then, then what is your, what
does your day look like at that point?
After that?
Well, it varies. Can like most people have
some traveling and teaching, you know,
cause I, I teach different centers
around the country and some in Europe.
Then I'm out and about.
But say you're at home and you
can do whatever you want. Yeah.
That's when I'm happiest.
Yeah.
Your hair.
Yeah. Well. Um, usually that
means that I am writing,
I am component putting together
talk and um, cause I do it,
it's like being a minister.
I do my weekly talk and that's kind
of where a lot of my energy goes.
But I'm also involved with, uh, we have a
meditation community here in Washington.
A lot of socially engaged
action initiatives are going on.
So I'm involved with projects like,
uh,
we were bringing mindfulness into the
schools in the area and that's it.
That's kind of amazing.
I mean,
just to imagine this next generation,
um,
training their attention so they're
able to be more collaborative so they're
able to be more emotionally intelligent
so they're able to find their center.
So that, that one really
excites me at night. You know,
spent some time working on that.
In fact,
the Congressman Tim Ryan and I've done
a number of presentations in the area,
two different schools
that, uh, and, and it's,
there's thousands of kids in the area
that have now been taking mindfulness
courses. So that's just an example
of something I'd be working on
that.
Is there a dedicated website for that
or can people find more information on
your own?
Yeah, well, um,
mine's m I N D s is the group that,
um,
that I've been advising and that's
affiliated with us and I think it's,
you know,
I'll,
I'll let you know before the end because
I'd love people to check it out there.
It's amazing what they're doing, the
kind of work they're doing. And in fact,
I'll tell you about one project that I,
that I really love, which is that, um, I,
I mentioned that Jack Kornfield and I are
collaborating on this mindful for day.
There's 40 day program.
Well we're mines has,
we're affiliated with mines
and we're going to be working
in one of very diverse,
very underserved,
very large high school in the DC area.
And we're going to bring mindfulness
to all parts of it. In other words,
they're going to do the training with
the kids and Jack and I are the this
online program or have all the faculty
and Admin and parents are going to be a
of the group that we work with.
They're going to be taking it.
And we've got on the
ground mentors. So, um,
the idea is to see if we can change the
whole culture of the school by bringing
the sand and there's so much research
now showing the beneficial effects for
kids that,
um,
but to have the parents also to
me is what's exciting. So we've,
we've been able to get some revenue enough
to get the first round going on this
and uh,
and I think it's going to be a very
cool pilot that can be done elsewhere in
other school systems.
Cool. I love, I love these types of,
of pilots because they can really set a
precedent and provide a case study that
people can replicate. So, uh,
I will put that whether we get to it
today while we're talking or afterwards,
but for everybody listening all to
put a link to that in the show notes,
I would like to ask a very self
interested personal question,
uh, in that is that I think also applies
to a lot of people listening to this.
So the,
if I look at my circle of
friends in Silicon Valley,
if I look at my circle
of friends in New York,
and certainly I think in many other
cities around the world or just in many
other places around the world,
there is an increasing,
uh,
severe problem with Fomo as we
call it here. Fear of missing out.
So this, this can manifest
itself in many different ways.
People feel like they can't stay away
from email for 30 minutes because they'll
get backlogged and there's a
fear of missing either a problem.
We were missing some type of opportunity.
Uh, in my particular case, you know,
I've talked to a number of friends
of mine who are involved with startup
investing and whatnot about
taking a startup vacation.
I would like to take a three month,
100% vacation from new startup
investments because it's become,
uh,
something of a source of stress for me.
I think things were very
unstable right now and uh,
irrational and the,
the feedback almost universally has been
you shouldn't do that.
Don't make any kind of public proclamation
because then you'll stop seeing deals.
And then before you know it,
you'll be out of the loop and then you
won't be able to get back into it when
you want to get back into it.
So this is very, and that,
okay,
as you might imagine, puts
me on edge because I, I,
I found that there are certain things
that I feel I need to categorically say no
to. Even if just for a period
of time I can't do it 80%.
If I tried to do at 80%,
then I'll look at everything in it.
It just becomes a self
defeating. Right. It did.
Did I won't make any progress.
So how would you,
how would you think about or
encouraged people to think about this?
This fear of missing out where they feel
like they constantly have to be in the
loop. We're accessible or
fill in the blank because it,
it seems to be a huge
source of stress for, uh,
for almost everyone that I know.
You're right.
And I think it's getting more so because
of the degree of the Internet and plug
it, cause we're always plugged
in on so many levels. You know,
the book the shallows and
did you read that right?
No,
I don't actually
can't remember the name of the author,
but it's really describing her technology
actually shapes and changes our brain.
And you know,
whether it's the,
the onset of typewriter changing
cause instead of handwriting,
which brings out a certain part
of our brain, um, you know,
having a typewriter but being
plugged in all the time,
our brain is changing and we're actually
taking it a lot more information,
but it a lot more of a shallow level,
not so dimensional.
And we've lost our capacity to actually
immerse and drop into the deeper,
more subtle dimensions of things.
It's actually a change in the brain
that people that used to be, um,
very avid deep readers just
can't get themselves to,
there's a kind of attention deficits
when it comes to certain things.
And what the Internet promote is the
sense of missing out because there's so
much coming in from so many different
angles so that you always got the sense
that you're missing it.
That there's just something else that
you need to be plugged into. And,
and one of my favorite little cartoons
of this man and a woman sitting in the
living room and he sang to her, you
know, if I ever become a vegetable,
just pulled the plug at which point she
goes over the TV set and she hangs out
the plug. And, and what I like
about it, it's just like we're,
we get, we get into kind
of an existential anxiety,
oh my not plugged in.
Like the world is moving on
without us and how to deal with it.
The first is what you're doing,
which is name it, name it,
and really get that this is
a product of the Times that,
that we're at a very speedy time,
the end.
And it's accelerating. Where,
um, you know, there's like a,
there's a relationship with the, the
Chinese word for buisiness that has to,
that's in relationship.
The heart killing.
Yeah. The speedier we get.
Yeah. You could feel it.
The left side of the character means
heart and the right side means death. Yup.
It's amazing.
Amazing.
And so I can say for myself
to him that when I'm in my,
like that fear of not being
prepared or the fear of missing out,
my heart's not so open. If my son
calls and I'm in the middle of it,
I really am not able to take in him
what's really going on for him because
there's some part of me that's
tense and on my way somewhere else.
So it feels like first of all,
to have the aspiration to be free
from that trance is the first step to
recognize what's going on and
know that you can be a more full,
more productive,
more wheel being when you're not
constantly being tugged around by that
something more or something else. And
then the second piece is, you know,
if I think of people that are really
good teachers or people that are really
good writers, people that
really have done the music that,
that those two people saw,
they retreat,
they, they unplug, they take space,
the,
the step out of the dizziness and allow
an open themselves to something bigger,
something wide or something more
mysterious and fluid and order for that to
happen.
And for you,
and I feel us in particular
for you because I feel like
you're, you've got, um,
you're very plugged in to the pulse and
a very good way and your sensitivity and
attunement, we'll get even deeper if
you could take sabbaticals. Agreed.
Because it, what'll happen is it'll
break. We all get habitual to some degree.
And the trick is,
can we keep on recognizing and out of
any of the habits that stop us from being
as sensitive and attuned as possible?
And,
and so you need a sabbatical to do that.
And what,
how would you contend with the,
the fear of that,
the unintended side effects of that
sabbatical? Right. So for the free,
right. So the friends I have, we're
like, dude, you can't do that.
If you make some kind of crazy public,
a proclamation or put out a blog post
about how you're taking a x month startup
vacation,
you have no idea what kind of cascade of
events you're going to trigger like you,
you're going to be and blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
So there's this kind of fear
mongering fearmongering that, uh,
I'd love your thoughts
on how to contend with,
first of all,
part of who you are,
10 is don't, you guys don't have to
try it out. I'll go ahead and try it.
All right. You know what's on the other
side? So part of it is just knowing that,
well, let me put it this way, there's a
palliative caregiver who said, you know,
who was with thousands of
people when they're dying.
And she said the greatest regret of the
dying is not living true to ourselves is
that we're living according to the
expectations or the cultural fears or
whatever.
So your whole path is about
playing the edge and not buying in.
And part of what that means is that
you're willing to feel the fear but not be
driven by it, right?
So that's where we get,
here's now we're coming back to
having tea with Mara for you.
It's go ahead and say, I'm,
I'm, I'm stepping back. I,
I'm taking a sabbatical from, you
know, whatever, whatever it is,
and then your process and it's an
important process. It's not like,
I wish I could sidestep this so I
could actually have my sabbatical.
Part of it is you are learning how to,
uh,
find your peace and balance and ease
in the midst of those energies of fear.
Right?
One of the interesting things to me is
that if you go to, in Asia, there's these,
uh, Mondalez, which are, you know,
filled with images and right at
the center of them a sacred space.
And in order to get to sacred space,
you have to pass through what are
called the animal headed goddesses.
And they're really fear and anger and
hatred and jealousy and point isn't that
you get the only way to sacred
space to encounter these energies,
but the,
with them not try to sidestep them.
So it's almost like it
is the path to face fear.
And then there's the question of well
how do we do that in a way that actually
feeds us and not freeze up know.
And um,
for me the way that I work with here
is there's a difference by the way,
between traumatic here and the kind of
fear we're talking about. Definitely.
Okay. So with non traumatic
fear, and by the way,
I'm doing a whole online course
on working with here in the fall,
which you know,
I'll,
I'll tell you more about because I feel
like for almost everyone I know really
what's going to free us most.
What's going to bring out most of our
creativity and most let us be intimate in
the world is to really learn how to work
with the fears that we run away from.
And in fact,
there's one,
one mystic who says there's only
one really good question, which is,
what am I unwilling to feel?
Okay,
that's a good one.
And fears what were unwilling to hear.
So it's like, to become fearless,
you need to feel fear and
be willing to be vulnerable,
be willing to have everybody tell
you, hey, you know, you're going to,
you're going to go offline and then you're
going to miss something to be willing
to feel that vulnerability
but not be driven by it.
Well, that's me. Reminds me
of, I'm paraphrasing of course,
but what Mike Tyson's trainer,
custom auto said in his,
at his peak,
which was the hero and the coward feel
the same thing. It's what the hero,
the hero does that makes them different.
And because Tyson was,
was terrified before getting
to the ring, oftentimes, uh,
just hard to imagine.
But true. Uh, the, um,
I like this. Yeah. I need to think,
make a couple of pretty big moves,
which, uh, which I've been meditating on,
but, uh, I've, I've been
frozen and not fried,
so I need to pull the
trigger on a few of those.
I think if you could have
a billboard anywhere, uh,
and you could have it say anything
that you liked, what, what a,
what would it say and where would it be?
It let's say realize and
live the loving awareness.
That's really who you are.
Where would you put that?
I'm not sure.
You know, where do you put it? Yeah,
sure. I put it inside everyone's
heart and mind. It's like,
I feel like,
you know,
the Buddha said it pretty
elegantly that if you're suffering,
it's because you're forgetting who
you are. You're, you're living in a,
in a smaller narrative.
And that really each of our jobs
is to start recognizing how, what,
what am I believing?
It's limiting me.
What am I believing that's
keeping me small, separate,
either feeling deficient, are
feeling superior? Because, you know,
I talk about the trance of unworthiness,
that I can honestly say that I am as
much in the chance trance of specialness,
his unworthiness, and both of
them caused stuff, you know?
Right.
No,
it's,
it's about really waking up and realizing
that there's a basic goodness here.
This,
there's a humanness and,
and alive in this and intelligence and a
lot of it's what we are and we all have
our particular qualities, but you
know, there's this basic goodness.
So a lot of what I'm doing and my books
and then my teachings is how do we pay
attention so we can come to trust that
and live from that and then look at each
other like,
so I can be listening to you and
sense pass any mask or persona,
just that, um, you know, just
that consciousness, the sentience,
the place that we're
really in the same field.
So many questions I could ask,
but I know we're,
we're probably coming up on time and
I don't want to consume your entire
afternoon, but I do have a few
more I'd love to ask. And, uh,
the, you're mentioning knowing thyself.
And actually before I get to that,
just a quick side note for people who do
face a lot of fire in the public world.
Uh, when I first got exposed
with the success of the
first book and it was turned
down by whatever it was, 27 publishers,
no one expected to do anything.
And all of a sudden I was
having to get 10 with a lot of,
uh, public facing an angst.
And, uh, someone said to me,
you're never as good as they say you
are and you're never as bad as they say.
And I was like, wow, that's good advice.
Uh, don't let it go to your head,
but don't get shopped off at
the knees either. The, the,
let me ask a couple of questions that
are, are less, maybe less serious than,
than some of those we've tackled, but, um,
feel free to answer or not answer or,
uh, however you feel you need to respond.
But, so the first is, um, what,
what music would people be surprised
to know you like or listen to?
I'm not sure if surprised.
I love Mozart and Beethoven.
Tickle music. Not Thinking that's
going to be surprised. You don't,
you don't listen to like Marilyn Manson
when you're working out or anything? Oh,
when I'm working out,
but you didn't ask me that.
You know, my son widened
my taste, so you know,
so I can then I have a capacity to enjoy
a whole lot of different art forms.
But you know,
I don't like a lot of,
I like silence and quiet so
I'm not, you know, I try to,
whenever I can have it quieter.
Got It.
Okay.
What about a guilty pleasure that is a
movie movie or documentary or TV show
that you really enjoy that might not
immediately come to mind if people are
imagining what a, that you
would like. Is there anything,
are you like a big legal,
a lethal weapon fan or any,
what was that series? I'm forgetting
it now that I love so much. You know,
Albuquerque and drugs and
breaking, breaking bad.
I went crazy for breaking bad.
I went so crazy for it that I would
be teaching a class and leading the
meditation and knowing
you didn't want to be,
I wanted to get home sooner so I could
catch him. You know? I mean, I love that.
Yeah. So that's one. Does that count?
Okay. Do you have a favorite documentary
or any favorite documentaries?
You know, my favorites are more just
because I have such a passion for it. The,
you know, any of the
documentaries about, um,
there's been documentaries about the
earth, you know, those kinds of things.
Documentaries about pharmaceutical
industry document. You know,
it's kind of the political ones that I,
unbelievers and that,
that undressed things. The
tobacco industry, you know,
there's been some
documentaries on racism better.
Like I just saw one called doing racism
or the illusion of race or something.
It's just, you know, right now,
because we're the times you're
bringing it more to our attention.
It's like we're seeing what's happening
in the daily lives of African Americans,
but we're just seeing like spot hits of,
you know,
unarmed African Americans being
killed. And then this whole, you know,
shooting and Charleston,
it's like anything that brings
that into our consciousness,
that this is not some distant other
having a bad experience. Now I man,
these are our brothers
and sisters part of our,
our world right here who are living
still on a daily way that is,
um, violent and oppressive documentaries
that show, that kind of thing.
Got It. Uh, this is, uh,
maybe a jarring segue from,
uh,
and uh, and, uh, be curious to hear
your response to this, but what,
what purchase of less than a hundred
dollars is most positively impacted your
life in the last six months or a year?
Uh, less than a hundred dollars. Um,
and they have to come back to that one.
We can come back down or it will be,
or we can table it.
Oh, we got some raspberry bushes that, uh,
probably pretty much less. And
they're like, oh my gosh, you know,
I just went out this morning and
picked a whole mess of raspberries.
And it's like,
I really like simple pleasures so
that my gown, well that's the gift that
keeps on giving to it's, yeah, yeah, yeah,
exactly. Oh, that's, I'm so jealous.
I wish I could walk out and pick
some raspberries right now. Uh,
so last, last question,
last of two, but the,
the t the last question is
kind of a parting question. Uh,
the advice
you would give your 30 year old self,
what advice would you
give your 30 year old self
to
profoundly accept and love myself as I am,
but I'm going to add on to that.
Um,
and this is more relational as I'd
like to speak to a little bit related,
you know, we do a lot of training
to be with ourselves in meditation,
but the missing component is how do we
train ourselves to be with each other.
And I would say to my 30 year old shelf,
take the chance of being
more vulnerable. Like, let,
let your vulnerability be there so that
instead of feeling angry and expressing
the anger,
stay with the anger and that she could
feel the vulnerability underneath it and
be able to name that. And this is
particularly in intimate relationships.
Like with my husband, we have a
ritual I and we buy a reteach. Uh,
we teach courses and bringing mindfulness
and meditation to relationships.
Um, which is one of my favorite things in
the world to be teaching. And uh, that's,
that's the message it's like
to be, have the, the nerve,
the courage to feel,
feel what's vulnerable.
You know,
that,
that thing I said before about what are
you unwilling to feel to feel it and to
be able to name it in the seal,
the relationship.
Because what happened just the way when
you name something inside yourself,
you're less identified when
you do it together. It,
it helps both discover a field of intimacy
that really is filled with compassion
and understanding that you can't get to
if you're not willing to be vulnerable.
And what is the ritual that
you have with your husband?
Well, we a couple of times a week and
we do this more than appliques formally,
like we have to like, it's on our
schedule, um, is, um, which is,
you know, Tuesday and
Friday mornings we, um,
we alter our morning routine some so that
we sit down and meditate together and
then we basically share
whatever's going on.
You know,
it could be in our lives,
but more is there anything
right now between you and
I and really feeling loving
and feeling open and that's
kind of the inquiry and, um,
and, and then to hold a space for
whatever's there so that nothing,
so we don't get into a habit of that,
you know,
of in some way covering over something
and then having something built and then
not be as tender and open with each other.
And we're,
you know, we're, we hadn't
been married that long.
We've been probably together for
about 12 years. And, um, you know,
and it keeps on growing and unfolding.
And I will tell you one very brief story
that, and one of our ritual sessions,
um,
I had this feeling like he was,
he was kind of like staying
on the perimeter and so
on. So at one point I said,
so how are we doing?
And he had that deer in the headlights
swept like, oh my God, sorry,
anniversary every guy in the
history of the world. Exactly,
exactly. To me the other day, she
goes, do you know what tomorrow is?
And I was like, Oh God, oh no. Yes,
I know it strikes terror in a man's
heart. I get it, but I get it. And it was,
and it was actually,
I could even feel it as I was doing,
it was very controlling move.
So he had that look and then
pull that into his iPhone.
And he said, Siri, what do you do
when your wife says, how are we doing?
And here's what she said. I swear
this is the truth. Very said.
You say,
I'm okay and you're okay.
And this is the best
of all possible worlds.
Really?
Oh, really? He's like, I
mean, I, he handed it to me,
I looked at it and I gave up. I said,
okay, let's go kayaking. I said,
drop this communication stuff.
Let's just go play
unexpected turn of events.
That's, that's amazing.
But I liked,
I really liked the idea of having these
scheduled checkins because it also
avoids the bubbling over a of these
conversations or discussions so that they
erupt at really inopportune,
uncomfortable times. Uh, right.
Minimize the Zippo doesn't eliminate
them, but it, it helps to mitigate that.
Well, what happens is when
they come at the wrong time,
we go into our old habitual,
either the sender attack
mode and what we and,
and then actually create the walls that
are the two we don't want. So it really,
it really helps just
like formal meditation,
it helps to have on-purpose sitting times
so that if something needs to present
itself and you need to work through
something, you're, you're available.
And then stuff will come
up at other times too.
But you kind of get more than
knack of how to work with it then.
I love it.
And if you could make an ask of
everyone listening to this and ask,
or a recommendation,
what would that be?
The real ask would be to pause enough
so that you can contact what's really
going on inside you and pause enough so
that you can look at another and see the
goodness that's fair and mirror back some.
Let people know.
Very good advice. Tara, I love your work.
I'm so glad you're out there
in the world doing what you do.
Where can people find you on that?
That web known as the interweb Internet,
Tara brock.com.
Yeah,
that's the simplest way.
And then get on my email list.
I,
I'm not a massive emailer. I mean, I keep
being told I should do that. I'm not,
but I do let, let folks know
then, uh, the different, uh,
in person and online courses
that I'm doing at the,
the ones that are coming up or there's
one on fear that's coming up that I'm
excited about. And Jonathan,
my husband and I are,
are teaching some relationship workshops.
So those kinds of things
you'll find out about
and the guided meditations,
just to reiterate that on
your site are fantastic.
I've listened to them while traveling
quite a bit just to take the edge off.
Uh, so I once again appreciate you
putting that out in the world for free.
Is there anything else you would
like to say before we close this,
this chapter?
One conversation?
Um,
I want to appreciate you because you know,
I've been talking about evolution and I
feel like you really are your curiosity
and your way, your way of
interviewing, you know,
there's one teacher says that attention
is the most pure expression of love and
your way of interviewing and also moving
to the world is deeply attentive and
courageous and sets a
model for us. So, um, um,
it's a pleasure to the whole hands.
Oh, thank you. Thank you. That makes,
that makes my day. I really appreciate it.
And hopefully we will get to meet
in person sometime soon and uh,
we'd love to, to see the
Potomac from the, from the, uh,
the perspective of where you stand with
your dog. That just sounds amazing.
So I really appreciate everything that
you do and of course everyone listening,
I will take the resources,
links and so on from his conversation
book recommendations, uh,
certainly radical acceptance and and
others and put them into the show notes so
you can find all of
that@fourhourworkweek.com
forward slash podcast all spelled
out. And until next time,
thank you for listening.
This episode is brought
to you by Vimeo pro,
which is the ideal video hosting
platform for entrepreneurs.
And in fact a bunch of my startups already
use Vimeo pro including wealth front
who uses it to explain how
wealth front works task, grab it,
use it to tell the company story.
And there are many other names you would
recognize among their customers, airbnb,
Etsy, et cetera. Why do they use it? Well,
Vimeo pro provides enterprise level
video hosting for a fraction of the usual
cost. Features include gorgeous
high quality playback with no ads,
up to 20 gigabytes of
video storage every week.
Unlimited plays in views and they
fully customizable video player,
which can include your logo, custom outro,
et cetera. You'll also get VIP support.
And you get all of this
for just one 99 per year.
That's $17 a month with no
complicated bandwidth or hidden fees,
and you can try it risk free for 30 days.
So check it out.
vimeo.com forward slash business,
that's B I n e o.com forward slash
business and use Promo Code Tim to get 25%
off. That's a special discount
just for you guys. So check it out.
vimeo.com forward slash business
promo code. Tim, and until next time,
thank you for listening.
Yeah.
Okay.